could we be heading potentially towards
not one but two wars right now US
military news has confirmed that a Navy
Strike Group is headed towards the
Korean Peninsula presumably as a
response to North Korea's recently
publicized missile programme North Korea
has carried out a number of nuclear
tests recently experts are predicting
that more could be on the way and North
Korea is moving closer and closer to
developing a nuclear warhead that could
at least conceivably reach the United
States and there have been some
indications from North Korea that it
might test and in an intercontinental
missile even though it's actually banned
from such a test under UN resolutions
those are restrictions that North Korea
has pretty consistently ignored and on
Wednesday North Korea test-fired a
medium-range ballistic missile from its
eastern port of sinpo into the Sea of
Japan and that came just months after
four ballistic missiles were fired
towards the Sea of Japan North Korea
says that it was provoked by military
exercises involving the United States
and South Korea which it believes are a
preparation by the u.s. and South Korea
to invade North Korea this is the Carl
Vinson strike group that has been
redirected from being on its way to
Australia for a sort of scheduled
deployment to the Korean Peninsula and
president Trump has said that the United
States is prepared to act alone to deal
with the nuclear threat from North Korea
according to Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson and here's where things start
to get a little wonky let me let me
first put up the quote from Tillerson
and then I'll tell you what is not being
said here Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson said on CBS's Face the Nation
president Z clearly understands and I
think agrees that the situation has
intensified and has reached a certain
level of threat that action has to be
taken let's keep that up on the screen
because the key words here are and I
think agrees this is so important
because this quote has been used to
report that China effectively the loan
even pseudo ally of North Korea is on
board with a mayor
Eric and military action against North
Korea and it is based on this quote and
when Rex Tillerson says president G
clearly understands and I think agrees
that is the opinion of Tillerson that is
not a quote from anyone in China
indicating that they actually favor this
and the reason this matters think back
to the Iraq war there was this poll done
very good poll by P IPA where many
people especially those who watched Fox
News thought that there was worldwide
support for the American incursion of
Iraq when in fact there wasn't and we
know that if you believe that other
countries support a particular military
action you are more likely to support it
as well it is not China's position as it
is currently known based on what
Tillerson said that they want military
action against North Korea the headlines
are all over the place pat very
misleading this is why we need
independent media right because you can
just put I think and you can say just
about anything after that and if you put
both things in the same sentence even if
you don't connect them directly yeah
people are going to perceive them as
connected absolutely that's exactly
what's going on that's exactly how the
headlines are being written and when you
look at the quote it's based on it is
bogus and is anybody realizing that the
supposed non interventionist Donald
Trump that was bragged about in contrast
to Hillary Clinton during the campaign
has evaporated there are some trumpets
that actually get it they are now what
we call former trumpets didn't lots of
you vote for Trump because Hillary was
going to get us into Wars and look at
what Donald Trump is doing multiple
possible military incursions are ramping
up very very quickly today's program is
made possible in part by Gamefly which
is sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games
through your Amazon fire stick or Roku
box and then use your mobile phone as
the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30 day trial for David Pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com forward
slash TDP s